I'm going to name a movie you tell me
was that Geffen shirtless or not
shirtless is no Bluff no top are you
demonstrating what that's for ETN movies
after dark people everyone welcome to et
at the movies where we get you ready for
what's hitting the box office this
weekend I'm ash Carlton and please
excuse my voice I was at camp and I was
yelling a lot I am John Boone please
excuse my face I got in a fight with the
rock which brings us to our movies this
week we got a twofer
we got Baywatch Baywatch we got pirates
of the caribbean dead men tell no tales
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales which is not to be confused
with hurts of the caribbean dead man's
chest which is an actual another movie
in the franchise but not this movie they
love the best but that leads us into
Ashley's college thesis about Pirates of
the Caribbean
she wrote literally what had to be mm
how many pages of 2,000 words I should
know this I'm a writer it wasn't that
you know about that long of a thesis but
I was watching the movies and there was
a couple of things that I was like oh I
feel like I need to recall that there's
not a lot you need to know before going
in there's more so from stuff you need
to just remember from previous movies
first thing you need to remember which
if you can't remember this I'm concerned
about you is Jack Sparrow played by
Johnny Depp he is a quick-witted pirate
gets away on being cunning he's a drunk
something like this
the second one is our other returning
characters will Turner and Elizabeth LAN
for Lana blooms Keira Knightley and the
fact that they got married and had a son
which we find out in the post credit
scene for at World's End that they have
a son named Henry and I married so the
third thing you need to remember is that
what happened to Will Turner at the end
of at World's End was that he was cursed
to the flying dutchman so in order to
kill baby Jones will Turner was mortally
wounded he was died so he was going to
die anyway so they cut out his heart and
put it into Davy Jones locker thus
cursing him to be the captain of the
Flying Dutchman Davy Jones ship so he's
immortal can't die but he can only come
on land once every 10 years that's the
Flying Dutchman and then you need to
remember the Black Pearl which was Jack
Jack Sparrow's ship that was cursed in
the first movie but we actually need to
remember about it is that before on
Stranger Tides we learned that the Black
Pearl was shrunk down and put into a
bottle don't ever even and that's where
the Black Pearl was that's their ship
right there's more there's more there's
more point number five captain's Hector
Barbossa and he was the villain of the
first movie who me tonight Geoffrey Rush
mutant eyes Jack Sparrow and took over
the Black Pearl him and he got it back
and then he was killed at the end of the
movie and then we find out that he was
resurrected to help rescue jack in the
third movie at World's End so he kind of
redeemed himself and becomes a good guy
as far as Pirates can go whoever turned
of frenemies for enemies and then the
last and final one is the compass which
was it's Jack's compass and whenever he
opens it it points in the direction of
whatever the user of the compass desires
the most it was a big part in one of the
movies but not really any other ones but
it comes into play a lot in this one
honestly if you didn't follow that
seriously rewind this clip go down here
scroller go back like a minute and a
half however long you just talked we
wash that off because it is important
and it does all happen to this movie yes
but they are leading us off with some
new cancers right we going into a whole
new light of this franchise we already
mentioned Henry Turner who is will in
Elizabeth's on that's Brendan stole
eight from the giver
handsome man came from great charisma
even greater eyebrows we also have
Kareena Smith played by Kaya Scodelario
in
is very cure nightly yesh Kiera
Knightley Leigh Keira Knightley II and
lastly we have the matador of the sea
the villain of the movie he's kind of a
zombie ghost
well not qualifying us I just call him
all skeletons but I guess he is he's
like a huge undead anyway Javier Bardem
plays them Javier Bardem is boo
real-life boo - Penelope Cruz
Javier sorry I just called you someones
boo but our very own Jenny direct oh
friend of the pot pod vlog what are we
doing here our sweet podcast yeah friend
of the pod Benny direct Oh sat down with
Javier and found out some advice he got
from Penelope and what it's like working
with Johnny Depp she told me you want to
have a lot of fun you know you're gonna
laugh a lot when you were with Johnny so
learned your lines because you may
forget about them and it's true see
what's right in a sense that when you
are working with him and he becomes
Spyro
then the first two or three times it was
like yeah that was great I mean I forgot
that I have to interact with them it was
so painful that he did to me I thought
he was probably the best part of the
movie
what did you think of Pirates well
there's fun bit and then the rest of it
I've seen you right I think it's
certainly the same old song and dance
but it's a song and dance I kind of like
it enjoy I feel like this franchise is
kind of stuck in a weird place where
it's getting repetitive mm-hmm Johnny
Depp is the same in every movie Jack
Sparrow is never gonna change and if you
have to be in all these movies how else
can it change I think I mean as long as
they keep selling tickets I think
they're just going to keep words and
repeating and that's essentially what
Jerry Bruckheimer said he said he's got
to cut that check welcome to Baywatch we
have another movie to talk about also
taking place at sea sea themed Baywatch
strictly for adult audiences rated R
this is not your aunt's Baywatch that
horny aunt that loved Baywatch this is
not for her well actually it probably is
for her because this one has Dwayne the
rock Johnson did you know that P
actually wants to be called DJ so
your wish is granted so it starts DJ in
the David Hasselhoff role and Zac Efron
in a role played by someone that you
would have no idea who they are even if
I said the name and then the villain
this time is Priyanka Chopra who is the
prettiest woman in the entire world
anyway ETS Kevin Frazier was down in
Miami with DJ DJ and DJ kind of filled
them in on how this movie came to be
well you know what we want to do we want
to make sure that the action was fun
with Baywatch you know we want to make a
movie that was fun but we also want to
make a movie that had great action so do
you like your Baywatch heart argh no
like I loved what they did with 21 Jump
Street 22 Jump Street and this was kind
of in line with that and I love that
idea really yeah this is not like a very
negative episode for me apparently I'd
be in a real downer and DJ you know I
hurt you but I've met the rock I'm just
kind of like you can't just plug in a
bunch of like penis jokes in the F word
and get laughs there are funny moments
of this movie there are certainly funny
moment but like so many of the gags are
just like a penis and we have this can
we have a little more insight on that do
we not we have a little more insight on
what we're all adults everybody is
trying to make a good movie everybody's
trying to work hard right we're all in
business together with you know time as
money we're working hard but the moment
a prosthetic penis comes on set please
every night it's a word twelve-year-old
boys again yes look at that come here
back yeah here please Val Venis are you
holding a card so now we're going to
play a game called because I spent a lot
of time trapping that I really didn't
see it it's called was that Efron
shirtless in this movie or not oh my god
okay dirty grandpa yes
shirtless neighbors two sorority rising
I'm gonna go shirtless bingo I probably
should have told you you also got that
first one correct okay again hairspray
not shirtless very good very good
seventeen again shirtless I'm sorry to
realize this might be the easiest game
it in the entire world let's say let's
say Charlie st. cloud
Oh shirtless yeah yeah but if you
defaulted to shirtless on all of them
you do pretty well me and Orson Welles
not sure what I thought that one might
stump you
apparently I know my Zac Efron shirtless
trivia High School Musical 2 oh not
shirtless shirtless multiple pods busy
jet oh oh and that last one to Lorax not
sure game sucks no I like to back up Ron
is shirtless all the time I should be on
Jeopardy what questions you think
jeopardy is asking I'm almost
embarrassed but I know that much Zac
Efron shirtless trivia I won the game
Zac Efron I were he's dancing for you
that's your victory dance
yeah what's rapid baby up let's wrap
this baby up which movie do you
recommend that everyone should go see if
you had to pick one I'm going to say
Baywatch and you know why I'm going to
say they watch because if it gets a
sequel maybe we'll get more Pamela
Anderson and I demand more Pam Moore Pam
oh yeah I'm going to go with pirates of
the caribbean dead men tell no tales
because I am just a little nerd for the
fee and I love it and I thought it was
exciting and that scene when I hear it
on the big screen is just magical you
know that there is also ocean and they
want yeah but there's no skeleton sharks
and they watch wait so did you think
that definitely keeps my ghost Austin
shocked that's all for us this week what
are we talking about next week Oh
am I good wonderful is that another
score you like hearing on the big screen
yes actually come back we're talking
about Wonder Woman see you next week
when we talk about Wonder Woman do it is
like subscribe all that stuff and Swiss
a comment give us eyes and we need it at
us whatever bye
you
[Music]